...
-Retiens la nuit...
Pour nous deux
jusqu'à la fin du monde.
Retiens la nuit...
Pour nos coeurs,
dans sa course vagabonde.
Serre-moi fort
contre ton corps.
Il faut qu'à l'heure des folies,
le grand amour
raye le jour
et nous fasse oublier la vie.
Retiens la nuit.
Avec toi, elle paraît si belle.
Mon amour,
qu'elle devienne éternelle.
Pour le bonheur
de nos deux coeurs.
Arrête le temps et les heures.
Je t'en supplie
à l'infini,
retiens la nuit.
Ne me demande pas d'où me vient
ma tristesse.
Ne me demande rien,
tu ne comprendrais pas.
En découvrant l'amour,
je frôle la détresse.
En croyant au bonheur,
la peur entre en mes joies.
Retiens la nuit.
Pour nous deux
jusqu'à la fin du monde.
Retiens la nuit.
Pour nos coeurs,
dans sa course vagabonde.
Serre-moi fort, contre ton corps.
Il faut qu'à l'heure des folies,
le grand amour
raye le jour
et nous fasse oublier la vie.
Retiens la nuit.
Avec toi elle paraît si belle.
Mon amour
qu'elle devienne éternelle.
Pour le bonheur
de nos deux coeurs.
Arrête le temps et les heures.
Je t'en supplie
à l'infini,
retiens la nuit.
Je t'en supplie
à l'infini,
retiens...
la...
nuit.